this is a pyroclastic flow it's racing
down the side of a volcano hot fast and
deadly this however is a replica created
in a lab in New Zealand but it's
providing new insights into this
dangerous phenomenon pyroclastic flows
are fast flowing currents of rock ash
and hot gas produced during volcanic
eruptions they can move at several
hundred kilometres an hour and can be
hot enough to kill in an instant but no
one knows exactly how these pyroclastic
flows move thousands of kilograms of dry
volcanic material should produce a lot
of friction but they seem to flow like a
liquid so what's really going on inside
it's extremely difficult to study a
pyroclastic flow on an active volcano so
these researchers made their own they
mined real volcanic material mixed it
with heated gas sent it hurtling down a
chute and filmed what happened through
heat proof glass they were able to see
the ash cloud on top and the denser
particles underneath but surprisingly at
the very bottom
they found that a thin layer of gas had
formed this layer was acting like a
lubricant decreasing the friction and
allowing the material above to move
further and faster
this new understanding of the anatomy of
pyroclastic flows could help
volcanologists make better predictions
for future eruptions and maybe this
volcano in a lab will help save lives
you
you